okay so um
uh uh of course you're aware of the i
mean first of all a comment um i do
think there's a deep connection between
um the christian models which is sort of
a two worlds mythology and descartes uh
dualism of mind and body so i think
that's an accurate historical
observation um
i talk a bit about that connection in my
awakening from the meeting crisis series
so um
in fact i often talk about christian
cartesianism as the as the link between
those so i think that's a good a good
historical observation
of course the the deep problem uh with
finding that division of res extension
and res cognitives um
to be the sort of final note on your
ontology is the problem that beset
descartes which is the problem that
spinoza immediately
recognized is that there's no possible
causal interaction between these domains
and you get the separation of right
reasons from causes and you get all of
these kind kinds of problems um
and so i take it that there is something
fundamentally wrong with the ontology if
it's giving us that kind of
deep i mean it strikes me as absurd to
say
that my mental states whatever they
happen to be in my physical states are
not causally interacting with each other
uh on an ongoing basis
and you know that
i if i if if i presume that kind of
dualism then of course i can also pick
up on your mental states because all i
get is your bodily behavior etc and if
there is no causal relationship between
your mental states and your bodily
behavior um then of course i can't uh
pick up on other minds
and so
i mean
you want i know you know this because
you've mentioned it in one of the one of
the talks i mean that ontology is though
is deeply problematic because it
generates these really really
powerful and perfect uh yeah dualism is
very difficult to get to work
and
i
think that the solution is relatively
simple res extensor and res cognitives
both exist in the mind they are just
different domains in which we make sense
of the world one is this mechanical
level of geometric perception and the
other one is hidden states
of intentional systems that animate part
of this world
and
the when a meditator believes that uh
res cognitance uh is uh separate from uh
res extensor and uh res extensor is out
there in the physical world and
experiencing the physical world and they
managed to
go to this state of reality construction
where this boundary between self and
world is obliterated and they suddenly
noticed this unity of the system and oh
my god everything is consciousness
they became pencilists uh
right it's that's a fundamental
confusion that results uh from uh this
error in the ontology
and
uh when i was young i stumbled on the
same uh issue as you just mentioned uh
if you are a dualist
how does this interface between
the causally closed physical universe
and
the mind work
there are some solutions to this like
for instance
occasionalism which means they just
happen to be synchronous but there is no
direct connection between them and
ultimately this is a form of epi
phenomenalism so uh it would not be a
violation of the causal closure of
physics if your
ontologically separate mind would be
reading it but wouldn't have right
access right so you could have this
physical universe mechanically clicking
uh
by itself but you could have the mind
looking at it from the outside but as
soon as the mind writes you should be
able sometimes to see certain violations
of the conservation of energy or the
conservation of information in the lab
and apparently you don't and popper and
eccles hope that it's possible to
basically
hide this in the randomness of quantum
events but still it would need to be a
systematic violation so i don't think
that this would work
and the attempts to
solve this problem i think that
they they don't work out
so i thought there is two possibilities
one is either we are an entirely
mechanical universe and there is no
conspiracy going on of course it's also
possible that the mechanical universe is
in some kind of simulation right so we
could be running in some kind of nerd's
computer and that is stationed in the
next
level universe and uh of course this
nerd could also interact with our world
and in a sense dualism in some sense
might be possible it could also be that
our minds indeed run on a separate
machine and interact with it but in this
sense every supernatural thing would
have to have a natural cause at some
level in one of the parent universes
just unfortunately this
intermediate level could be a symbolic
one
and the symbolic universe is a magical
universe